NASA engineers are working to bring
supersonic travel back to commercial
aviation just over 70 years after the
sound barrier was first broken the Space
Agency is pushing new boundaries CBS
Evening News anchor Jeff Glor recently
broke the sound barrier with NASA to
learn about the research Jeff good
morning Nora good morning and Happy New
Year the only commercial passenger plane
that flew faster than sound on a regular
basis was he now retired concorde back
in the 70s 80s and 90s but the concorde
was only allowed to go that fast over
the ocean because supersonic flight
creates a big side effect a loud
explosion of energy that is unsettling
and can be damaging a sonic boom today
NASA is working to lower the boom so
airlines can quietly hit those speeds
and cut travel times for everyone in
half seven decades after the first sonic
boom when I dropped them that was 14
October 1947
I heard sonic boom and we knew right
there that he had brought in a new air
force a new supersonic air force Bob
Cardenas flew the b-29 bomber that
dropped Chuck Yeager's x1 out of the sky
and into the history books once we could
go beyond the speed of sound it was the
gateway to space that momentous events
70 years ago did lead to space travel
but not supersonic commercial air travel
mostly because of this
[Music]
series of loud booms caused when a
supersonic plane creates audio
shockwaves that sound like bombs shape
the earth and can even break windows so
they banned supersonic flight over land
NASA aerospace engineer at herring is
trying to fix that that's the one is
ready he and his team are working to
lower the blast force and cacophonous
sound of sonic booms we showed that we
could reshape the front of the plane and
make a quieter boom on the ground this
is completely redesigning planes right
they've designed an experimental plane
called a low boom flight demonstrator
to be built within four years the
ultimate goal make supersonic commercial
flight a reality for everyone if it
takes five or six hours to get from New
York to Los Angeles in 20 years you hope
it takes how long half the time six-hour
trip will be done a three-hour trip
we'll probably be doing 600 miles an
hour-ish
until the demonstrator is done it falls
to NASA test pilots like Nils Larsen to
create low booms with today's aircraft
to do that Larson has to execute a
complicated series of aeronautical
torsions with current jets like this
f-18 Hornet we're gonna roll inverted
pull down to 53 degrees nose low roll
out and then we're gonna start a dive
pull out to about three and a half Gees
sounds easy yeah it's not that hard on
this day Larsen has a new copilot
starting to look like he's fixing to go
flying
I need the Nils shades and a mission to
show us how low the sonic boom can go
[Music]
back down on the ground herring in his
microphones are listening and collecting
data but to execute the low boom
maneuver Larson first must climb to
49,000 feet roll and a few seconds later
back on the ground got a boom somewhere
neighborhood of 0.4 herrings initial
data shows about an 85% reduction in the
power of the boom NASA we use their new
data to design these new planes but
unlike our flights that plane will not
have to go invert it at 49 thousand feet
and then dive straight down thanks to
its shape it'll create a low boom simply
by flying level and really really fast
kudos to Jeff Glor I know they say never
say never I heard that on The Oprah Show
years ago never say never but I can say
I will never i ain't never doing that
you say I would love to do it again I've
done it once before gone seven G's it
was a long time ago but I am up for that
any time why don't you have children and
a husband I feel the need the need for
speed and they once said in Top Gun well
I will be down here cheering you on
no thank you but thank you Jeff Glor a
nice job